we're all friends of the Fallout
universe yeah
the fallout the Bethesda fallout
universe the WWE universe think about I
hate the WOB universe it's the worst
acronym thing I've ever seen in my life
yeah 10 sec man jumping off things
anyway fallout you review for for
GameSpot last year
you've played a bunch of it yeah I've
put 150 hours into that campaign and I
you know finish the automatron dlc yeah
and then I know you're getting at is the
survival mode yeah so this is what they
they didn't put into the game originally
it was in new vegas hardcore mode they
have a hardcore mode in Fallout 4 but
it's just a survival mode but it wasn't
basically it's like this is like 2.0
survival mode yeah right like they added
more things to it yeah but what's
comment now the beta well it's in beta
and soon is survival mode proper which
adds a significant amount of changes to
fallout 4 like not even like oh we've
like made ammo carry you know has in
conference again it's like do the list
what do we go there it's it's a pretty
phat list so yes ammo now it takes wait
mini nukes that you carried around with
like you know not to take for granted
they're 12 pounds each right stimpacks
you can't carry you know I think many
people can agree by the end of the game
you have like 300 stimpaks and you're
playing on very hard I know I've heard
people tell me this you you can just BAM
your way out of it but yeah those have
weight now so you can only take like you
know roughly ten around wow you now
factor in hunger thirst and fatigue so
you can get tired the only way you can
save the game is by sleeping in a better
mattress and you see them everywhere
which is suspicious and then the real
kicker is there's no fast travel and
there's other things down that they
attack on including you know you take
more damage you can deal more damage and
you get also things so it food health
and fatigue factor your your AP bar now
okay just like your vats and your sprint
if you don't manage any of those three
it takes away like rads due to health so
you specially lose all those so if you
don't do anything you can't run anymore
and like in like less than you know 20
you have to basically keep adding in
check and it also affects what they now
introduce is your immune system so right
I didn't talk about this in the video I
did over the weekend but that also means
that animals who are poisonous or you
can eat basically you can like break
your bones easier you can you can get
illnesses like different types of
illnesses which some of them can only be
cured if you go to a doctor it sounds
like you just it's a tough life out
there and I love it I mean it yeah it
seems like they could have just done the
oh we're gonna add in a bunch more you
know health fatigue water management
systems in here like we're in New Vegas
and like we're in the old follows but it
seems like they've gone like full like
the long dark on this well if you jump
off something too high you'll break your
leg
and then you have to walk the whole way
like taking a fast couple completely is
like holy [ __ ] and and there are things
that I like really agree with or pre
strong it with in some things I think
that could be toned back like fast
travels pretty pretty brutal like not to
have it at all
is real brutal and there's no like a la
carte menu where you can say oh I want
like this this is okay but like let's
turn fast driver Buccaneer and what I
hope to come out of this is you know
specific mods that cater to like
breaking these this whole mode you know
down to its core but you know you can at
least like you could conflicts a like
okay well what about fast travel like a
little bit you know like in between
settlements right which is horrible yeah
what's your style yeah posts whatever
but the but taking out fast travel to me
was really cool in that okay now I'm
looking at a map that like I can't just
warp to an area haven't been or like you
know close by now I'm like required to
like explore again like kind of like
what the first third of your experience
was was like seeing all these cool new
places yeah but once these are fast
traveling between them you're not
getting any of the of encounters you're
not getting like a lot of this breathing
world that eventually by the end of game
you just don't you don't see anymore
yeah and so like when I played just
recently I like had to go to a different
area because the game still has like
those side quests that are like
procedures procedurally generated it's
like hey
judging by your map we don't think
you've been over here so now these
things open up and as does that Lane
that you've never seen before so like I
was you know hunter fit the hours and
scheming I'm like walking through an
area I've never I've never been yeah and
that like that's also like scary there
right because then you don't super see a
society want to go off the beaten path
because like in your video you had this
whole thing where it was like okay you
like woke up in the morning so you had
the most daytime because at nighttime it
gets like harder or I guess so you I'm a
skirt I'm skinny
and you like you brought like these
weapons because you were doing this type
of mission right but then you're like oh
there's a sewer I'll just go in the
sewer because the Fallout game and you
do whatever you're like oh no I
should've done this I'm dang like
swarmed by people getting sworn by
people I'm now drinking sewage and you
know that's the craziest is like the
more you the more you drink you know
water that isn't purified the more rad
you get okay well then I think I'll just
pop a couple of these rata ways guess
what those make you insanely dehydrated
you're just digging a grave and it's
real cool and yet and the craziest thing
sounds great but you know it's survival
of survival games like you know me so
this like his home but like the other
thing which I really adored was like
okay now I can't carry as much goddamn
ammo as I like you know like if it's the
one thing that like you walk into a room
in that game you're like alright where's
the ammo I'm taking all that right I'm
like you know super nut my abilities to
get more ammo because I know I can just
flip that like no problem sell it yeah
sell it like no you have to pick I'm
going through my ammo like I'm taking
like a hundred bullets hundred fifty
bullets for each of these guns guess all
I can like afford to carry and I get
down there and I run ammo so this is the
coolest part was like I'm picking up a
damn pipe pistol something that like you
got over or like within the you know
first two hours of the damn game like
screw these pieces of [ __ ] I'm using
this thing to like just survive like it
was this while I'm like how is this
possible the game is making use a crap
weapon
it sounds like this is the way fault I
was like meant to be play that's why I
fell when he told me and I gave the game
at nine I gave it a really high score
boom like man I would have given it a
higher nine like touching on like you
know but I think I think what a lot
people agreed on was like why why do I
need to build a base right oh I had this
right am i building a base like I was
into it I got you you get into the idea
and then you're like this is really
janky and I don't even know like I'm
just coming back here build another one
build another stuff why would I want to
do it kind of like I enjoyed it just for
the sake of it because it was like yeah
that's like a fun thing to do but you're
right there was like no utility to it
and so then you realize like with this
game-mode I mean it's hard to say
whether like this was like you know on
the backburner the entire time this game
was made I'm not going that far but what
becomes a parent is like okay I'm
looking at my map I got Diamond City in
the middle that's a safe safe haven
you know sanctuary in the top if I just
made you know to southeast and southwest
bases I got my stuff covered now I know
I don't have to go all the way home I
can establish those supply lines that
they like try to incentivize but like
who cares yeah I'm going back to the
same place every single time so you just
start realizing like all right here is
now a map that I'm thinking about routes
and like waypoints and and making that
efficient and and as far as travel and
yeah yeah it almost like makes all that
stuff makes way more sense in the
context of the wider game is there
benefits of sleeping on a real bed than
to a mattress yeah there so there's like
you know if you can imagine the world
you walk into a building there's like
just a mattress or sleeping bag the
sleeping bag would be the lowest of them
you you get so you get tired you need to
sleep a a sleeping bag will only take X
amount of that fatigue away like in real
life real bad so you have to eventually
to wipe that fatigue clean you have to
stay or sleeping you know like a like a
nice bed mm-hmm like a California king
right what kind of a breakdown we
talking on the sheets over a thousand
yeah it's tough it's a tough life Jeff
404 says this is how this game should
have shipped kind of feels all right
I mean just bits of it that seem like
like everything as far as cooking like
you like cooking stations like no now
you're like oh yeah of course water
boilers but of course now I'm making
food I'm making a sandwich because what
else does it do it eliminates my hunger
and it gives me health and I'm delicious
and probably less encumbrance because
you're taking all these individual items
and combining them right and certain you
know like a deathclaw steak gives you
like what else and not health but like I
think some type of perk you know ility
yeah so like you compare that just
impacts like stimpaks eventually seem
like well why not go for the twofer
you're right right like yeah they give
you so much more like stimpaks almost
become less like less important yeah and
also another big one which is actually
really terrifying to like where stimpaks
you know again like toward the other
gamer you know you have 300 these things
you just you're just like oh as you're
taking damage you just hidden your mash
in one I'm wine quick save quick save
yeah exactly
now I think the stimpaks take like
triple amount I'm water despite then
like you're booking it like out the
combat just slows down significantly
because you're just scared I don't know
being scared and in this game like had
its effect I feel like in the in the
early stages and by the end of it you
got I mean you get power so early on yes
but also I'm gonna fight a bloody death
clone the first 10 minutes of this game
right and also here's another good one
is is power armor you can take a lot
more weight right like a lot I think
it's like almost double and we're
thinking like alright well no problem
I'm over encumbered but I'll just put on
my power armor and it's like 10 more
slots oh it's nothing like nothing at
all like power armor is just something
that you can use this like a defensive
measure like you're not like able to
like carry more stuff does that mean UK
your companions can carry like it's
everything that is diminished as well
the same
cent were like your your already your
inventories cut in half they can take
about half amount of stuff right now you
got these robots like I can go on
forever now you got these robots who
like from automaton automatron which are
like again like you play the
single-player campaign of that and it's
like I'm done mmm now what do I do now
these robots are even like more
essential because you start can like you
know you get really nitpicking gritty
we're like okay I'm gonna like pimp out
one of my robots and just have this
person carry will be able to carry and
just be like a you know storage mule
yeah so you can like customize your like
robots to paint that like one of them I
the one I was using I put on a
regenerating health field right yeah so
like it when I'm out of combat she'll
like boost my health up oh wow I'm
acting so anyways guys that's pretty
cool last point on this I guess is
actually yeah what I want to ask you is
does this and beta it's actually it's a
free update it's it's not out yet for
everyone right how did you opt into the
beta was a difficult no it's it's Oh as
far as like how to do it yeah yeah yeah
it's it's only pieces that feature in
like every game you know good properties
and it's like the beta section you just
you turn it on
but I will say man it was rough a sports
crashing yeah like crash the desktop
like so off them in the forms and
everyone's just crying like yeah my
saves are no mess up god like to thank
God and so I finally got to work doing
whatever was you know like windowed mode
I don't you yeah bunch of just random
stuff Windows XP oh I got work but like
you know it's you know beta I'm one of
as the player level like we did you
would you start the game with this or
did you go in with write the character
no I went in with like a level 49 gras
and that was still really difficult to
play this game from a new save would be
insane right just like that first I mean
I'm thinking up until power armor like
yeah that's gonna be rough that's gonna
be rough it's yeah but it's totally like
you know if the game for I feel like so
many people like halfway through just
gets boring and not challenging you just
don't want to retain your character like
holy [ __ ] this is the way I like it on
alright Rob thank you so much
father for survival mode